just getting that breaking news about
the Colorado state supreme court uh
saying based on the 14th Amendment and
uh former president Trump's actions
during January 6th that he is not
allowed to be on the ballot uh in
Colorado just receiving word from the
Trump campaign a reaction to this ruling
quote unsurprisingly the all Democrat
appointed Colorado Supreme Court has
ruled against President Trump supporting
a Soros funded left-wing group scheme to
interfere in election on behalf of
crooked Joe Biden by removing president
Trump's name from the ballot and elim
eliminating the rights of Colorado
voters to vote for the candidate of
their choice Democrat Party leaders are
in a state of paranoia over the growing
dominant lead president Trump has a
massed in the polls they've lost faith
in the failed Biden presidency and are
now doing everything they can to stop
the American voters from throwing them
out of office next November the Colorado
Supreme Court issued a completely flawed
decision tonight we will swiftly file an
appeal to the United States Supreme
Court and a concurrent request for a
stay of this deeply UND Democratic
decision we have full confidence that
the Supreme Court will quickly rule in
our favor and finally put an end to
these unamerican lawsuits again that's
from a trump campaign
spokesperson um and obviously we'll
follow this as it heads up we are
talking about the polls tonight as this
breaking news comes down hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else